I gotta say this is the end of the long
award season but an amazing one because
we got to see a lot of you how's it feel
to be here tonight
you know what this is the party that
everybody wants to come to this is the
invitation that everybody wants and
guess what you got one I got one thank
you okay I'm here at the Vanity Fair
party thank you pulled up in my little
Maserati for the evening yes it's been a
very nice season baby giving success
it's giving money Maserati they said
would you like to have one I said
forever or for the night well it's only
for the night but Cinderella you know
we'll take it okay so she got the
carriage unlocked right outside the
street I love it you know tonight you
tweeted that you were rooting for Miss
Angela Bassett I mean what did
triumphant return for her right in the
sense that like you know she's getting
her well-deserved flowers after 30 plus
years in this video that's right 30
years from the last one to this time
sometimes the nomination is all you need
and that was all that Queen needed so
I'm very happy for her I'm happy for
Jamie Lee you know Jamie Lee was all in
her feelings for her mother and her
father and I shared that sentiment you
know because I know that my parents are
working it from heaven for me I know
they are so and kill oh my God come on
to hear him in the tears and the joy and
the Daniels I mean the fact that I've
heard them speak over and over at so
many different Awards events and they
were prepared for this moment everywhere
everything all at once yes I mean
between you and key I feel like this
award season has been nothing but
sermons you know just filling us with
wisdom and inspiration well I have to
tell you something it took me 40 years
to become an overnight sensation and I
am enjoying the shine I am enjoying the
flowers I am enjoying the time and I am
so thrilled that tonight is the last of
it because mother is tired I believe
that how your feet doing very good only
the shoes that fit me well there you go
can I get your reaction to Rihanna's
performance come on your girl Riri
here
is
Riri I love you and let me tell you
something you got guts because I tried
to sing when I was pregnant and it ain't
easy but you go girl you have all of my
respect yes are you excited to see
Quinta host SNL and do her thing oh my I
just found out about it I was like oh my
and you know she's gonna be great
because she's going right back into her
wheelhouse from the BuzzFeed days I
can't wait but I wanted I hope she's
does oh he got money I hope she does
that
[Music]
thank you